in Deutschland starten jeden Tag über
1500 Flugzeuge in die ganze Welt hinaus
ich habe mir als Aufgabe gesetzt einfach
mal zum Flughafen zu laufen und den
ersten Flug zu nehmen der auf der
Anzeigetafel erscheint wir starten heute
von Dortmund aus davon hier nur Maschine
nach Europa fliegen und ich schaue
einfach mal wo ich lande kurz Ergänzung
dazu noch bevor es jetzt gleich zum
Flughafen geht und zwar werde ich zu der
Anzeigetafel gehen und da stehen ja dann
die ganzen Flügel ich muss sagen erstmal
Dortmund ich bin natürlich schon das ein
oder andere Mal von Dortmund ausgezogen
es ist auch hier in der Umgebung der
nächste Flughafen für mich und auf
dieser Anzeigetafel stehen immer
unfassbare Ziele von den Orten habe ich
noch nie gehört deswegen glaube ich es
kann echt spannend werden und ja ich
versuche dann einfach den frühesten
möglichen Flug davon zu buchen weil man
kann Flügel halt zwei bis drei Stunden
vor Abflug buchen und wenn er jetzt
steht z.B keine Ahnung London 11:40 Uhr
ich komme um 11 Uhr an und kann diesen
Flug noch buchen werde ich noch nehmen
falls ich dir nicht mehr buchen kann
nehmen wir den Flug danach wenn ich dir
nicht mehr buchen kann den danach und
irgendwann
und ich bin gespannt auf die nächsten
Tage es wird bestimmt geil ich bin
ziemlich spät dran let's go
und jetzt muss ich mich auch wirklich
beeilen UPS weil wir haben schon 11 Uhr
und ich will ja noch was vom Tag haben
so Leute was geht ich bin jetzt
mittlerweile hier in Hamm am
Hauptbahnhof das geile ist ich habe
direkt schon mein nächsten Zug verpasst
wegen Verspätung ich komme jetzt noch
später am Flughafen an aber ich wollte
auf jeden Fall mit dem Zug zum Flughafen
fahren weil ich weiß ja auch gar nicht
wann ich zurückkomme und vor allem wohin
nicht zurückfliege deswegen könnte halt
sein dass Rückflug nach Düsseldorf oder
Köln günstiger ist wegen wollte ich mein
Auto noch nicht stehen lassen und jetzt
heißt es hier war habe ich übrigens so
ungefähr der hässlichste Bahnhof
Deutschlands mit den größten Asis und
einer davon steht genau hier Leute ich
bin auf jeden Fall in Dortmund am
Flughafen und jetzt gerade meine Kamera
nicht rausholen weil das Wetter so
schlecht ist oh mann ey ich musste
gerade noch zwei Kilometer laufen das
kann doch nicht sein ich bin klitschnass
Alter
ich will doch nur irgendwohin fliegen so
leute bitte passt schon nass geworden
schauen wir jetzt mal alter Mann geht
ich muss auch wirklich dazu sagen ich
habe echt vorher nicht nachguckt welche
Fliege heute fliegen schauen wir mal so
Leute wir haben doch auf jeden Fall ganz
oben rum 14:30 Uhr schon weg
Größe schaue ich mal ob ich den noch
bekomme ansonsten Tirana London Danzig
Kattowitz okay ich habe von diesem Lasi
auf jeden Fall noch nie gehört aber wir
schauen mal ob der noch frei ist let's
go okay Leute schauen wir mal larsi oder
hieß das ihr sie Rumänien ja wenn Sie
jetzt noch gibt dann fliegen wir dahin
okay ihr könnt Ihr sehen der Flug wird
mir nicht mehr angezeigt das heißt da
kann ich nicht einsteigen ich muss mal
kurz gucken welcher der nächste war also
als nächstes haben wir Tirana in
Albanien da würde ich hin safe also
eigentlich ganz spannend aber das ist
leider der 1945 Flug und nicht der 16
Uhr der jetzt gleich ist auch weg mist
dann geht's weiter mit Danzig schauen
wir mal bei den noch Kuchen können
eigentlich müsste dagegen weil das
müsste von der Zeit ja noch passen dann
sich geht 16:55 Uhr dann würde ich sagen
versuche ich dir mal schnell zu buchen
165 €, Danzig in Polen da war ich noch
nie ich habe auch keine Ahnung wo in
Polen das liegt aber klingt eigentlich
ganz spannend also ich würde sagen das
Ziel haben war wir fliegen nach Danzig
let's go
[Musik]
so Leute Check-In schnell vorbei
übrigens auch weg wir fliegen jetzt nach
Gedanken um 16:55 Uhr ich habe gerade
eben sogar mal geguckt das ist sogar am
Meer an der Ostsee echt geil also ich
freue mich schauen wir mal ich habe auf
jeden Fall echt Bock also das Reisen
noch mit echt richtig Spaß ich habe
übrigens auch einen neuen Rucksack wie
man sehen kann und ja let's go
ein Baguette noch mit Käse
das geile ist übrigens auch noch an den
Reisevideos klar ich versuche euch auch
ein geiles Video hinzu ballern nur ich
kann das meiste steuerlich absetzen kann
man ja mal so transparen sagen so wir
müssen auf jeden Fall hier zu Geld 4 und
Folge jetzt aber nach dem Wickelraum
Baby change
[Musik]
also eins muss man auf jeden Fall wieder
sagen Wizz Air mach dir einen Namen alle
Ehre Leute Tipp wenn ihr mit Whatsapp
entspricht weil sonst zahlt man 30 €,
also da wurden richtig viele Leute
rausgezogen naja mir ist egal jetzt
geht's los
[Musik]
leider ist das Wetter nicht so geil wie
erhofft aber naja
ich frage mich gerade warum die fünf
Sterne Hotels und dann sich so günstig
sind schaut mal 75 €, 69 €, Alter
[Musik]
ich muss jetzt auf jeden Fall erstmal
von hier aus irgendwie in die Innenstadt
kommen aber anscheinend gibt es hier
eine railway station das ist ganz gut
weil das günstiger oh Kamera dreckig ja
dann fahren wir mal hier hoch und ich
habe mich jetzt übrigens für das
Fünf-Sterne Radisson Blu Hotel
entschieden weil das von der Lage her
glaube ich am besten ist hat 75 €
gekostet pro Nacht also echt ziemlich
günstig
[Applaus]
irgendwie klingen die Bahnen hier so wie
Busse voll komisch
oder
also Tickets hatte ich gerade schon
aussteigen müssen problemlos nur leider
ich muss noch fünf Station weiter okay
Zug ist nicht weiter gefahren ich bin
jetzt irgendwo gestrandet und bin jetzt
einfach in einer Mall hey ich habe keine
Ahnung ich verstehe hier gar nichts die
Sprache ist interessant ja
Mann
in Polen den haben mal so mit so Autos
rum
also was soll ich noch nie gesehen ich
bin so verloren gerade aber ich habe mir
jetzt nur bestellt das kostet nur 5 €
für 20 Minuten okay jetzt muss ich
erstmal finden
[Musik]
schaut mal polnische Allianz Arena
bin ich denn jetzt hier gelandet also
das uber hat mich jetzt umgerechnet 5,50
€ gekostet für 20 Minuten Fahrt echt
wenig ah okay bin jetzt aber glaube ich
direkt in der Altstadt von Danzig
gelandet ja wow krass okay das ist nicht
so geil aus aber da schon wir werden
dann sich heute auf jeden Fall auch noch
ein bisschen erkunden ich möchte auf
jeden Fall einmal zur Ostsee weil da war
ich noch nie der erste Eindruck ist
wirklich geil ey das sieht richtig
richtig schön aus hätte ich gar nicht
gedacht also natürlich kennt man dann
sich aber das ist eine schöne Stadt ist
hatte ich jetzt nicht auf dem Schirm
aber so anzukommen ist schon mal geil
und wir gehen jetzt erstmal ins readison
blue fünf Sterne Hotel für 70 €, also
das konnte ich mir natürlich nicht
entgehen lassen ne und da kann ich auch
schon lesen Steakhaus nein eigentlich
will ich meine Challenge weiterführen in
jeder Stadt wo ich bin ein
traditionelles Gericht und ein lokales
Bier das wird zuerst und übrigens Leute
bevor ich wieder vergessen wenn ihr die
Reise Videos feiert würde ich mich super
freuen wenn ihr alle mal vielleicht den
Kanal abonniert weil mir macht das auch
sehr viel Spaß und ja da freue ich mich
drüber dann knacken wir bald vielleicht
auch mal die eine Million 10000
Abonnenten ganz cool wie sieht's auch
fresh aus okay ab ins fred ist im Blut
wow damit hätten sie mich auch abholen
können
[Musik]
Alexander
so eingecheckt im Hotel auf jeden Fall
super Netti Dame und wir gehen jetzt mal
aufs Zimmer ich habe sogar einen
kostenloses Upgrade noch bekommen
hallo ja stabil also ohne Witz ich hatte
noch nie so ein krasses Hotelzimmer für
75 €, das ist übrigens mein neuer
Rucksack er ist cool
ja das machen wir heute noch weiß ich
gerade auch noch nicht eine Minibar
gibt's hier eine anscheinend nicht
einmal Kaffee
Hunger ich ruhe mich jetzt auf jeden
Fall erstmal kurz aus und dann machen
wir noch Danzig unsicher weil ich will
ja wissen was hier so geht ne so Leute
ich habe mich jetzt auf jeden Fall
einmal ready gemacht bisschen frisch
gemacht so ich zweimal noch genauso aus
wie vorher aber die Kamera bleibt hier
weil die ist eine Belastung ich weiß es
noch ein bisschen random dass ich
alleine unterwegs bin aber Plan ist
jetzt ich habe ein richtig geilen
Burgerladen rausgesucht hier in der
Umgebung und ich habe noch nie in Polen
einen Burger gegessen deswegen würde ich
den unfassbar gerne testen und danach
gehe ich einfach mal alleine durch
irgendwelche Bars und guck was da so
geht wir müssen natürlich das lokale
Bier probieren und morgen früh wollte
ich dann einen polnisches Café aufsuchen
und dann haben wir auf jeden Fall
lokales Bier und traditionelles Essen
glaube ich abgehakt und ja gerade wenn
ich dann noch in Bars gehe ich kann ja
nicht mit der fetten Kamera darum meinen
ach so und ich möchte auf jeden Fall
jetzt noch zu mehr auch noch heute abend
einiges vor ich weiß ja gar nicht wie
lange ich überhaupt in Danzig bleibe
aber es wird auf jeden Fall noch
interessant wow also ich muss wirklich
sagen
bin schon beeindruckt das sieht echt
schön aus hier hallo meine Liebling
das gehört auf jeden Fall hier
anscheinend ist ja ich muss jetzt ich
werde schon wieder angesprochen werden
so ich konnte meine verfolge jetzt
abschütteln ich wurde auf jeden Fall
jetzt gerade hier so auf dreimal gefragt
ob ich Bock habe in den Stripclub zu
gehen dann mache ich so nee und dann kam
auf jeden Fall noch so andere Jungs
vorbei und die meinten sie suchen
irgendwas wo sie sag mal vorsichtig
gesagt dicker ich bin gerade mal 100
Meter gelaufen was geht hier ab
schade Leute das hinter mir war jetzt
der Burgerladen da gibt's das gerade
kein Platz mehr das muss ich woanders
hingehen oder ich warte keine Ahnung so
nächster Track Burgers ja komm warum
nicht
so Leute polnischer Burger ist da hat
mich 10 € gekostet mit der Cola zusammen
umgerechnet also da kann man auf jeden
Fall auch nicht meckern in Deutschland
mittlerweile in einem vernünftigen
Burger habe ich immer mindestens 15 Euro
los mindestens so Leute ich muss sagen
Burger war ganz okay ich hätte mir jetzt
irgendwie besser vorgestellt der war
irgendwie so eine Mischung aus Burger
und Döner wie so eine Tzatziki Soße
keine Ahnung der hat mit dem empfohlen
war okay na ja ist nicht so schlimm
dafür wird das Bier umso besser wir
gehen jetzt noch mal hier abchecken ich
habe schon ein paar Bars gesehen ist
halt ein bisschen random weil ich so
alleine unterwegs bin und ich glaube
hier sind sehr viele polnische Studenten
und so aber na ja schauen wir mal was
wird
was wird so jetzt geht's auf jeden Fall
mit dem Scooter hier ans Meer
Scheiße Leute ich habe mich ein bisschen
Verfahren hier ist jetzt Containerhafen
und manchmal bin ich so ich bin einfach
manchmal zu optimistisch wir müssen auf
jeden Fall noch sieben Kilometer bis zum
Meer und das kann ich mit dem Scooter
jetzt nicht machen weil der hat noch
fünf also uber suchen
[Musik]
ich habe keinen Plan wo ich jetzt hier
gelandet bin also Strand sieht anders
aus okay Leute da vorne ist glaube ich
das mehr dann habe ich das wenigstens
erreicht einmal die Ostsee zu sehen wie
sieht es auch super interessant aus ne
man denkt es auch nicht aber danzig ist
riesig also hier wohnt zwar noch eine
halbe Million Menschen aber das ist echt
eine große Stadt also du brauchst von
dem einen auf die andere Seite gefühlt
so lange wie in Berlin ich komme gar
nicht drauf klar dass da jetzt einfach
das die Ostsee kommt
so hier kann man noch duschen
okay Leute
die Ostsee schön einmal eine Muschel
anfassen haben wir das erreicht ab jetzt
eine Bar so für eine Stimmung her hier
ist es so ein bisschen wie ein Krimi
finde ich aber echt ein schöner Strand
also im Sommer ist das hier bestimmt
geil ich dachte hier ist irgendwie noch
so eine chillige Strandpromenade oder so
wo auch ein bisschen was los ist aber
hier ist ja nichts ja das hätte ich
vielleicht vorher mal nachschauen sollen
gut also ich bin hier wieder gerade mit
dem Regen diese beiden Mädels da mit den
Regenschirm die versuchen da alle
möglichen deutschen Touristen in
irgendwelche komischen was zu locken und
ich dachte mir ich gehe jetzt einfach
mal eine rein die ist hier hinter mir
wir schauen mal was da so geht let's go
Josef kabarber
[Musik]
okay Leute auf jeden Fall ziemlich cool
echt schön Design drin ich habe mich
sehr wohl gefühlt auch wenn ich alleine
unterwegs war und jetzt gehen wir noch
einfach weil ich dachte komm bevor jetzt
schlafen gehe schaut euch mal dieses
Bild hier an das sieht echt blöd aus
oder und zwar ist das ein alter
Luftschutzbunker da ist jetzt ein Techno
Club drin und da gehe ich jetzt einfach
mal rein
das ist auch einer von nur zwei Clubs
die hier auf haben heute deswegen ich
dachte mir ich schaue mir das einfach
mal an oder let's go so da haben wir es
Bunker ja dann wollen wir mal
[Musik]
guten Morgen muss sagen ich habe echt
richtig gut geschlafen hier
ja Aufstehen wie ist denn das Wetter
heute so das ist übrigens auch nein es
regnet schon wieder aber immerhin haben
die in die Lobby Regenschirme gehangen
ne Leute ich habe auf jeden Fall
wunderbar geschlafen habe jetzt meine
Sachen schon zusammengepackt wir haben
gerade 39 und ich gehe jetzt noch mal
durch die Innenstadt zeigt euch dann
sich bei hell und wir gehen was
frühstücken ich habe mir schon einen
Kaffee rausgesucht da freue ich mich
drauf und dann würde ich sagen schauen
wir mal was der Tag hier heute noch so
bringt also das Wetter dann sich hat auf
jeden Fall besser sein können es ist
schon wieder am Regnen ja na ja gestern
hast du eigentlich auch ziemlich viel
geregnet ich bin auf jeden Fall
ordentlich nass geworden aber jetzt bin
ich mal auf diese schöne Innenstadt bei
Tag gespannt
[Musik]
schön aus kann ich euch schon mal geben
da ist wieder so eine Promotor drin dass
ich da nicht belabern die wollen euch
immer nur in irgendwelche Clubs
reinbringen hier das ist echt krass da
waren irgendwelche Bars wo man reingehen
sollte ich habe das auf jeden Fall nicht
gemacht und einige von euch haben ja
auch bei Instagram geschrieben dass ich
das lassen soll und ja jetzt geht's was
frühstücken
[Musik]
da sollte ich jetzt dann rein unbedingt
wissen Berry good ja hier bin ich
gestern Nacht zwar auch schon lange aber
also wir sind echt super viele von
diesen kleinen Gassen mit den hohen
alten Häusern
[Musik]
also Leute ich muss sagen das Frühstück
war echt super lecker ich hatte einen
Croissant mit Pesto und Mozzarella habe
ich so auch noch nie gegessen keine
Ahnung ob das hier normales aber kann
ich echt empfehlen und ja ich habe mich
übrigens dazu entschieden dass ich jetzt
noch weiter fahre mit dem Zug bis nach
Warschau da bin ich nämlich auch noch
nie gewesen und deswegen Steppe ich
jetzt zum Bahnhof gleich könnt auch noch
ein bisschen länger hier bleiben aber
ich habe Danzig jetzt so die Hauptsachen
glaube ich gesehen und konnte den
Eindruck entwickeln deswegen dachte ich
mir kommen schaust dir war schon auch
noch an ich denke aber dass ich das
Video hier schon mal beende falls noch
irgendwas witziges passiert blende ich
euch das noch ein ansonsten hoffe ich
natürlich ja das Spaß beim Anschauen für
weitere Reisevideos Daumen nach oben
abonniert super gerne den Kanal und ich
bin mal gespannt muss als nächstes
hingeht und wenn ihr so Ideen habt wie
jetzt diese zum Flughafen gehen und
einfach den ersten Flug buchen schreibt
das auch mal in die Kommentare oder mir
bei Instagram da bin ich auf jeden Fall
immer offen für haut rein ciao